wordid necrophilia they're quite normal
people just with different passion a
woman cursed with a secret too terrible
to reveal don't love only the dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello everybody and welcome to episode
29 I think it's episode 29 by a 13
o'clock podcast hope you guys are
enjoying the show we have seen that
we've had some fans on our YouTube page
that's pretty cool that seem to watch
all our shows and seem to like them and
that's pretty awesome
yeah in the the podcast is doing good
too yes
so we appreciate everyone's support and
if you like the show I'll put a link to
the project's Entertainment Network
patreon page and they have shirts and
sticker in the buttons and stuff like
that you can get if you give them a
dollar two months and you know there's a
lot of other cool podcasts on their
network as well and I'm sure they would
appreciate it yeah we were you know I
kind of want to avoid it and monetize in
this show but I think we're probably
going to monetize this show yeah we are
thinking about it and the motors move us
up in the algorithms but what sucks
about it is that they'll probably put
commercials on it yeah and I mean you
know we already put commercial on if
you're at father's but you know I don't
know we'll we'll see we'll see how it
goes we're thinking about it so you know
don't get too bummed out we don't know
if we're going to do it yet well anyway
so today we're kind of doing a morbid
kind of topic yeah I originally wanted
to call this the show grave rapist yeah
the grave robbers more like great
breakers
yeah but I'm not sure if any sex really
happened with these two cases one of
them possibly yeah so maybe that's not
quite an accurate term yeah basically
we're talking about two cases of
necrophiliacs now necrophilia aside from
being pretty gross I mean a lot of
people know it like in context of like
serial killers because like a lot of
serial killers were necrophile you know
Edie and obviously um you know Jeffrey
Dahmer Edmund Kemper I think even Ted
Bundy was had some necrophiliac
tendencies but the thing about that is
that yeah here's Bing if you're already
a serial killer and then if you are also
a necrophiliac but it's just kind of
like you know that's just kind of like
this not frosting on the [__] cake you
know to me because it's like oh he's a
serial killer oh and by the way he's
also a necrophiliac because of course is
a I think kind of do that anyway right
so it's like it's not terribly
surprising so I kind of thought these
two guys cases were more interesting
because they're actually not serial
killers and we're actually kind of
normal people well supposedly
well seemingly normal where it doesn't
do this no that's like seemingly normal
people who just had some really
interesting fork liberties let's say and
one of them seems to be an echo
necrophile I think the other one is kind
of in question in it yeah okay yeah okay
there's questions in both cases but
they're both super weird and they're
also kind of these case are also a
little bit sad I feel like they're a
little bit sad tell us what the cases
are well the first one we're going to
talk of the second guy were in a sock
that is probably a lot better known but
the first guy I came across this guy
when I was researching the other guy and
this is actually a pretty recent case it
happened in Russia and his name is
Anatoly moskvin and the interesting
thing about Anatoly is that like I said
he was actually a really well-respected
member of his community he was academic
he had a PhD in Celtic studies he was a
linguist he did all kinds of
translations he was like really
well-known dentally translations deaf he
spoke 13 languages um you know his
colleagues and friends and stuff like
that thought he was a genius
what she does sound like a genius all
right but as with a lot of these kind of
super genius people also usually a
little percentage of crazy mixed in
there too I'm not really sure why that
happens but it does seem very
I think he had that thought is slightly
autistic yeah now yeah he did kind of
seem like that because he was kind of a
loner kind of an eccentric he lived with
his parents he never married he never
dated they think he might be in virgin
who um but you know that's unconformity
now
yeah I'm 66 yeah yeah born in 1966 now
he was also aside from all of his um
academic activities
Anatoli was also super into cemeteries
and death rituals and you know kind of
Mythology about death like across
cultures and to that end he has written
several papers and stuff like that on
different cemeteries like around his
area and Russia and all this other kind
of stuff so he's done like all this
research and he also would write for
this and I love that in this part of
Russia where he lives which is actually
I can't pronounce the name of the city
but it's like the fifth largest city in
Russia and um they have a weekly
newspaper called necrology that's just
it's about like um cemetery lore and
like famous people's deaths and things
like that and I'm like that's kind of
Awesome if they have a weekly newspaper
for that subject but um so he wrote for
that like a lot so him being and he was
all into graves yeah grave war yeah yeah
yeah historic yes we went and came to uh
and funeral practices and as it happened
the pencil and that's kind of how he
ended up getting caught because in the
area around where he lived you know
there are a great deal of cemeteries and
things like that and the authorities
began to notice a lot of grave
desecrations and you know bodies being
stolen and stuff like that so they
initially enlisted anatoly to help them
figure out who was doing it because he
was an expert like he had walked around
to all these cemeteries like in a seven
mile radius and all her stuff and was
like broke down all the dead people
names and kept all the cat track of all
the graves and he was buried there and
stuff so they kind of enlisted him
enlisted his help to find out who this
group who was doing it I didn't know
that the graves were being robbed um oil
and service yes Brooke and plus there
were things missing up like sometimes
like the metal you know the metal
plaques like that are all in some tombs
and stuff were taken off words and
things like that so you know they asked
for his help and he's like sure sure
saying okay but then they start delving
a little bit more into the case they
searched his apartment they get
suspicious because I guess he's actually
kind of where's they get suspicious
they search his apartment and they find
that there are 26 life-sized doll in his
apartment that are like dressed in these
kind of colorful clothes and you know
they look like doll what I mean you can
see picture them online there's pictures
of them all over the place they just
look like dolls you wouldn't think
anything of it but guess what guess
what's inside those dolls mummified
little girl yeah
mummified little girls that's what's in
there now any how many did he have he
had 26 of them although they're not
entirely certain like if that because
the original the original charge the
grave desecrations they were like there
were over a hundred of them over a
hundred 50° so they all know like if you
stole that many bodies and it rover just
pieces of the body in other arab
desecrations are they all little girls I
don't think so okay
it didn't really specify them for us but
all of the mummies that they found in
his houses were girls like between eight
his about six and fifteen okay
and so here's what he had done he would
go to a cemetery like he was fascinated
by death obviously he was also
fascinated by mummification like how you
do it and stuff like that and in his
house he had all of these notes and all
this kind of stuff about how to mummify
bodies like he was learned and how to do
it right and so he also had like man
like all the bodies he'd taken and stuff
like that and so what he would do is he
would go and you know and take the
bodies and for a while he would just
take them and then mummify them and then
just kind of bury them like kind of back
where they were like near a house it was
not borrow yeah he would just kind of
borrow him for a little while and then
you know then he started bringing them
back to his house and making dolls out
of them like what he would do is he
would mummify them using like salt and
baking soda and then he would kind of
like you know start wrapping them and
clothing and you know like a mummified
like bandages and stuff like that and
then he would dress them up and then he
would kind of he covered their faces it
looked like was kind of like nylons or
socks or something like that and then
you would like paint faces on there like
with nail polish and stuff some of them
look like they didn't really have faces
but maybe that was just the pictures or
therapy yeah but um you know it's just
like this super creepy and like I said
they also also yes why do applause why
not why not real paint I don't know
maybe he thought nail polish would last
longer because it was more of an enamel
I don't know where maybe you liked the
look of it all look they don't look too
artistic to me don't know realist they
don't they look actually yeah they're
they're kind of kind of amateurish
they are very amateurish and I mean you
know he's working with a bombing a
camera but um yeah so he was like and he
was you know stuff them full of you know
fabric so they would look like a person
and then she stuck the abdomen up put
average fabric yet and then and then
sometimes he would put like wax wax
masks over their faces and so here's
wigs on them and he has my thing I don't
get when you turn a body into a mom he
doesn't become kind of like beef jerky
yeah I mean I'm not how well I'm not
sure how well his mummification checking
I be flexible yeah I don't know how many
I'm sharing around like this you know
wooden a wooden statue or something
yeah a trimer pretty weird now this guy
and I gotta admit I mean you know it's
super creepy to keep mummified little
girls in your house
I'm not saying that Elina he's not
totally enough but I feel kind of sorry
for him too because you know obviously
this shit's not right and they were and
this or he's like okay wolves so they
arrested them right in 2011 and actually
they just arrest him it's you know
desecration of grave desecration of dead
bodies whatever which is illegal and he
would have got five years in prison up
to five years but they actually did a
psychiatric evaluation and discovered
that he suffered from paranoid
schizophrenia huh
now here is what he said and he actually
surely before he was convicted he wrote
an essay and I believe it turned up in
the college 'is that magazine I was
talking about earlier but I could be
wrong about that where he said where his
obsession with dead bodies and
particularly the dead bodies little
girls came from he said when he was a
kid he was super into cemeteries or
either he was super into cemeteries or
his parents were always taking him to
walk around cemeteries he was always in
cemeteries when he was a kid
and he kind of had a fascination with
them now he claims that when he was
little he was at a cemetery and there
was a funeral for a little girl going on
in the cemetery and somebody that was at
that funeral for some reason pulls him
over to the body and made him kiss the
girl on the forehead we're like kind of
forced him visiting I wanted to rush I
don't know like so I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what I
said and he said that's kind of what
started his weird obsession
like with these little girls now it
should be noted that like I said as
weird as this is there is no evidence
that he was having sex with them you
know what I mean so it wasn't like a not
fetishistic in that sense right um
mostly his motivation was that he
thought that the little girl like he
felt bad for them and he thought that he
because they had died so young
and he thought he was protecting them
and that if he preserved them then they
could be brought back to life
with black magic and that they would
have their bodies there when they came
back to life okay
I don't know you buy it you think it's a
real boat of wood I don't know that's
what he said and like I said he was
psychiatrically evaluated and they said
yeah this guy's all right yeah well
maybe and he and he said to that I mean
because a lot of different grades like I
said were desecrated and stuff like that
but he said what he would do is when he
found out that a little girl had gotten
killed or you know that there had been a
funeral for a little girl he would go to
that grave and he would lay on it and
listen and he said and if the little
girl told me that she wanted me to take
her out that I would take her it's like
but if I didn't hear anything that I
would just leave her where she was so he
thought that he was helping these little
girls that didn't want to be in the
grave anymore and he thought that
eventually they would be brought back to
life which you know that's pretty sad if
he really does feel I feel like that's
weird yeah I mean yeah but you know
that's why he said that these little
girls were calling for him that that he
needed to save them okay and now they
said that he was aware that it was
against the law right but that he had a
higher purpose right exactly he thought
that saving these girls was more
important than what all was so you know
now he also I guess he was also bummed
out because you know like I said
probable version but he'd always wanted
children and he didn't have any they
even said at one point he tried to adopt
a daughter but they wouldn't let him
conceive as a single guy and he was too
poor so um you know they wouldn't let
him adopt rude so he was kind of bummed
out about that but um like I said they
don't know it doesn't appear that he had
sex with this with these dolls I'd kind
of be surprised if he didn't but yeah he
was pretty he might have been nothing
you know they say he did hang out with
them like
like sing to them and we're and actually
I think some of the other like one essay
that I read about it in Russia the rumor
was that he he would put music boxes
inside the bodies so that the dolls
would sing relaxed to him yeah you know
what I mean
no evidence of that no I just yeah I
just read that like that some Russians
thought that and apparently there's
there's a thing now there in that area
of Russia where like if someone died
like you were having a funeral and it
was like an older woman they'd be like
oh well at least you at least she stays
like Superman always really takes little
purple which is [__] awful that is
awful it's you know what it what it
smelled like this up see that's what I
mean it was letters didn't complain now
or just dull yeah now yeah I do I feel
like he was like constantly like
probably soaking it in pursuing them
occur for human for breeze and all of
our I have a hard time not seeing
photographs of these dolls I have a hard
time okay
I have a hard time so even that the
parents didn't take something was up
they probably that all your a man that's
a dead body
yeah I don't know it's like when I first
saw them I was just like what the hell
is that about
they do kind of look like I mean you
know they're a lot crazier when the
proportions of the bodies it's obviously
that's a skeleton or body yeah I mean
the face doesn't look too good but I
would man you would think you know no I
don't know that is so creepy girl there
you go like this is right yeah he had
like a whole bunch yeah this is the
right I mean how big is this apartment
is what I want to know like because
they're saying apartment I don't know
how big the apartment is right and like
I said you know his parents lived there
too you know they were gone a lot but
obviously they were there sometimes it's
like how close approximate I mean
Anatoli you can see in the photograph it
couldn't been very big Amino since the
words were tearing around yeah the room
looked very small and I mean Anatoly
looked a little bit like a [__] he had
like 60,000 books and
they're kind of like all in stacked on
the floor and stuff like that because
like I said he was one of those like
weird super genius kind of people but
also a total nutcase yeah you know but I
said Nike I mean what happened here is
it eventually you know they didn't put
it in prison because of his mental
illness so they actually put him in a
psychiatric hospital and I think every
now and then they kind of review his
case to see if we should let him out no
yeah maybe not the money still in there
so he is still in there now they only
arrested him in 2011 so this wasn't a
terrible long time ago right but yeah he
still is in in there yeah and I don't
know it detected that children yeah it's
like that that part it just makes it
just rich it's just very suspicious to
me that there are no little boys in
there yeah that's a girl yeah yeah yeah
I guess that is rude I mean like I said
I'm not you know I'm like a hate on the
dude it's like and the weird thing it's
like he doesn't look like I mean because
there's pictures of him online there's
gonna look but um he doesn't look like a
weirdo well where do I think you could
bring something back to her wife Jesus
science or black man yeah like this like
you know what I mean like he doesn't
like sometimes you see like you know
necrophiliac for serial killers in the
Lego well yeah obviously because they
look like that but he doesn't he looks
pretty just looks like a normal day
pretty much okay but yeah so that's kind
of scary and you know I don't know like
I said I kind of feel bad for him that's
all when we started talking about doing
this topic the first thing I thought of
one of my favorite short stories and you
guys should look it up it's called a
death in the family by Miriam Allen
Deford now they made an episode of Night
Gallery out of it but the episode of
Night Gallery is not quite the same as
the story now the story I read it I had
it in like one of those Alfred Hitchcock
anthologies that I love so much when I
was a kid I still have it I think it's
Carly up in the attic but in the story
and it kind of reminded me of this
because there was a it was a mortuary
attendant or mortuary owner who who was
like a lonely bachelor he never you know
had a family or anything like that and
he got the idea to start stealing bodies
that he likes that were in good shape
and embalming them and then
setting them up like down in his
basement he had like this really nice
basement all laid out with a fireplace
and stuff like that he had like a whole
family and the end the point of the
story they liked the beginning of the
story was that he gets a dead little
girl dropped off on his doorstep by
these kidnappers that had kidnapped her
for ransom and they didn't get the
ransom so they killed a little girl and
then they dropped her off there so he
had like a big you know quandary about
whether he should call the police or
whether whether he should you know adopt
this little girl is his dead person
family yeah yeah so and that's it like
an old s from the sixties that story so
and also I should note too that see this
is what happens when you're researching
a podcast like this and you end up
finding out all kinds of like weird
facts that you didn't know like if you
guys seriously go read the Wikipedia
page on necrophilia it's a hoot well
it's best leave a section on animal
necrophilia because here is something I
never get never occurred to me that
necrophilia is actually pretty common
like in the animal kingdom which you
wouldn't think that that would have
evolved I guess or that it would still
be around but it's actually very common
and not just you know oh the you know a
frog is like humping a dead frog that's
got run over by a car whatever like that
which does happen once rod went on for
eight hours answer yeah humping this
rock I was like wow I'm kind of
impressed also catch it haha you can't
go anywhere I get it okay also
homosexual necrophilia is kind of
promises for particularly among birds
birth yeah though and some of them not
dead bird feel terrible and some of them
will kill another bird and then bucket
like a male bird will kill another bird
and then [__] man it's not like it's not
like every member of the species does
that but it's a pretty significant
percentages are yeah and I love kinda I
think on I think it was on the Wikipedia
page where there
we're talking about like a pigeon that
was hopping one who's got head got
crushed and then broke like that like
man and I'm altar crap did you take
advantage it is we're right there man is
like if they don't care that it's like
not gonna like any that is ridiculous
yeah either gonna use it up for it gone
nothing goes to waste in the animal
kingdom as well alright y'all [__] of
that to listen there's a lizard yeah if
you go on the like I said we going to
Wikipedia pages on Necker feel I'm sure
I'm on a list somewhere like all your I
can Wikipedia pages I go to yeah but uh
although I'm not as weird as the person
had to write this samurai but yeah there
is a there is a picture on here okay uh
one of those big monitor type lizards
yeah it's [__] a corpse you're
ridiculous key things into right now no
they don't maybe they don't really know
it's dead per se this is not getting
away yeah maybe yeah yeah I don't know
not thinking about the death part of it
yeah they're just saying well it's just
when I'm over just laying there too so
might as well yeah might as well jump
right on it yeah that was good oh and
all all right so it's coming about up to
the halfway point so we're going to take
a break and and when we come back we're
going to talk about the much better
known case of mr. Carl tans allure look
at of United some oh yeah and I mean
there's been like a lot of a lot of
stuff that's here in Florida when it
yeah it was okay the original Florida
man yeah before the original porkers man
sorry you guys I'm from Florida I don't
know what the hell is wrong with
everybody down here but anyway so we're
going to take a break we'll be back in
just a minute
rocket entertainment liquid from record
podcast every driving token time
learning a lesson and imake super you
pro-wrestling
in the hot spot featuring interviews for
they lovin coming in is your stars there
is people that shoots well it works you
can only hear the mount of project
entertainment and there's like a very
much
however subculture corsets and clothing
is our favorite store for unusual
clothing shoes and accessories they
offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
checkout subculture online at subculture
corsets comm set subculture corsets calm
make sure you use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount subculture
corsets calm or visit their store in
jacksonville florida just off i-95
project Entertainment Network presents
Buttercup of doom with your host Kelly
Ellen just a girl a girl who writes
horror and thriller fiction talks to bug
jumps in puddles and now hosts a weekly
podcast full of opinions advice and a
touch of gypsy wisdom whether it's
current affairs or social media
nightmare join me as I rant and rave and
opera book big old bucket of common
sense
Wednesday I'm Buttercup of doom hollow
her rapping the dawn by Jenny
specializing in posters and flyers
special rates for fans and artists
quick turnaround time book and CD covers
consultations through email or Skype
logos and packaging
payment through PayPal
as in promo materials satisfaction
guaranteed visit the Facebook page
hollow earth design or email pecking 8
at hotmail.com
[Music]
okay you're necrophiliacs now we are
talking about the case of Karl Tendler
original Florida man
the original Florida man I'm sure there
were some before that I'm sure this is
Florida man before there was even a
Florida there's something in the [__]
water down here debonair is good trend
he is [__] debonair well he's not
I mean he's not actually from Florida
like a lot of people aren't I am but um
you know a lot of people aren't he was
actually a German he was born ajar and
he moved here later now he's also known
by Karl von Cosel or causal or Count von
Castle he's not account for whatever he
thought he was the [__] I guess I guess
so he was the cow yeah also kind of a
respectable dude now the weird thing
about Karl tan blur is that I don't
think that he had well if he did have
like necrophiliac tendencies prior to
the you know the one incident that made
him famous he must have kept him way on
the DL because I don't think there was
ever any hint that he was up to anything
like that okay bye music yeah but he but
again he seemed like a fairly normal
dude he was a radiologist he kind of
look like a mr. peanut a little bit yeah
yeah that peanuts it was it was suspect
with it was not time it what's that
[__] take-home I don't know I bought
you one yeah mr. peanut yellow monocle
the monocle there you go why couldn't I
remember that word I don't know
but so Carl Taylor he moved to
Zephyrhills Florida and he had a wife
and kids at the time all right but then
for some reason he decided he was going
to leave the wife and kids in
Zephyrhills and then he moved to Key
West all right and he took a job in the
marine hospital there like I said he was
a he was a x-ray tech or a radiologist
rather now probably a separation but you
know back in those days they kind of
kept that stuff on the down-low
yeah yeah basically a divorce
by a fella I'm sure that it might have
been now they had two kids one of the
kids died at ten years old I think of
this area and the other one live but you
know but he I don't think he moved here
until later but like I said he seemed
like a fairly normal dude right so he
moves down to Key West he takes a job at
the Murray hospital as a as a tech and
then in 1930
this woman comes to the hospital for
treatment she's 21 years old and her
name is Maria Elena Malaga deployers
she comes in with her mother now she has
tuberculosis oh yeah which you know it's
almost and is almost always deadly but
pretty much yet in 1930 it was so she
comes into the hospital and Carlton's
were sees her and is immediately in love
yeah he's an old guy at this time yeah
he was certain he was fairly old boy
privacy yeah he was a lot older than her
now the interesting thing about why he
immediately fell in love with her was
that he claimed that ever since he was
young he had been having visions of
dreams about this distant relative and
the distant relative told him that his
soulmate was this particular girl and
showed him in his dreams what this girl
was like so evidently when Maria Elena
walked into the hospital he said that's
her that's who I've been seeing in my
dreams all this time and I are meant to
be together
who made that up I betcha he's right but
I'm just saying that definitely is
anyway but I mean he must have like
really fallen for her hard because
there's some pretty [__] weird [__]
yeah I think he saw her I thought she
was hot and then he did what he did and
then after we got caught he had to make
up an explanation
oh you ever stand
my ancestral spirits were telling it
with it yeah just like the I was just
like innocently returns like there was a
higher purpose
right yeah yeah and there are like some
other similarities so I just trying just
by necrophilia yeah true now okay Elena
was which was what they called her
usually like I said she had some Urkel
osis now handler was not a doctor doctor
but he decided that he loved her so much
and he was going to treat her right okay
and so the family were like kind of okay
with this because he seemed you know
genuine and he seemed like you know he
was all into her and stuff like that and
he would pretty much it's ounds like he
was stealing like x-ray equipment and
stuff like that from the hospital like
bringing it to their house Wow to like
to treat her at home Wow and he was
giving her yeah he was giving her like
all these you know medicines and things
like that and he also kept professing
his undying love for her he brought her
presents he brought her jewelry watches
a lot
yeah watching what okay well now she
responded to this see there's really no
record of that right and different yeah
he would probably just kind of like
whatever old guy sign us for the next or
whatever it's like they're really like I
said there really isn't any any record
of that she was all into him too or you
know she was she had tuberculosis she
thought it wasn't thinking about he's
drunk yeah she was 21 years old like I
said she probably wasn't thinking about
you know working it out at the diner -
right so you know even after uh you know
all of his you know efforts on her
behalf she still died because it was
tuberculous now I wonder if his
treatments you know if they're you know
first of all he's practicing medicine
without a license he wasn't really that
deal able to do that but I wonder if he
was using the best treatments of the day
or could just make pulling out his ass
yes miss me I don't really know I mean
look ahead he did have some medical
knowledge because like I said it was the
radiologist so he probably kind of knew
what he was doing I would imagine maybe
maybe
soon as well as anybody else goes on
that's what I mean because tuberculosis
was almost always fatal in 1930 so you
know it's not it's probably no it's no
you know work on his medical knowledge
that she died because she probably would
have died anyway yeah but um yeah she
ended up dying more than a year later it
was in 1931 in October and Karl tans
lair he paid for her funeral he
constructed this huge like mausoleum
yeah yeah there's pictures of it it's
like a really big you know in saying in
key what'd you have in mind he had money
he wasn't poor again but um and the
family would like I said again the
family was okay with it right so I'm not
sure like maybe he didn't really come
off as creepy to them because they
really I mean they seemed to give him
every you know they didn't really be
like no that's okay or you know back off
or anything like that right I mean you
know yeah I guess it's cool that he's
paying for her funeral and they all have
to do it and all this other stuff but I
don't know at first I think they didn't
think it was creepy woman no to us it
seems kind of creepy yeah because it's
like you know yeah what what happened so
he paid for them on the lam right and he
started visiting the mausoleum all right
every night he would go and sit by it
okay now she's sealed in there though
right yeah the Crypt inside when she had
the key to the key yeah Antoine I had it
built a lot of times when you walk into
the mausoleum now the coffin it's like
in a crypt that yelled into the wall you
don't usually concrete or something well
see here's like that or did he have an
access to the casket itself see that's a
wall he must have right because see
here's the thing since he paid for it to
be constructed I'm assuming this is it
respect that they did it's in his
specifications and he was thinking and
he didn't they're molesting that vibe
well I don't know if he molested it
while it was in there right but he would
visit it for a while without taking it
out oh yeah I mean he would just go and
visit her in there letting it cook it
tonight abroad oh man
and then apparently after a while and
this was this was like a year and a half
later he decided that he didn't want to
go to the you know to the mausoleum
anymore he wanted her by him all this
her out of there and he hadn't done any
preservations or anything on not at this
point now she was just getting involved
yeah yeah that's about that'll keep him
yeah kinda date lead decay anyway did
you yeah and like I said this was a
significant amount of time later yeah
okay significant amount of time did I
notice so he goes to the cemetery with a
toy wagon I know a Radio Flyer haha
whatever I'm assuming that I could just
picture it
I can picture the scene know mr. peanut
down there picking toy wagon with it
yeah yeah with a penchant for yeah yeah
yeah so here's the thing
much like Anatole in the first part of
this show uh Carl claimed that when he
would sit by the mausoleum and you know
and hang out with his dead girlfriend
that she would talk to him and that she
kept telling him get me out of his all
consensual yes I was in his office of
the Dead Can consent sure sure they
ghostly told me repression vigorously
told me yeah so you know he said they're
in singer and she was please please call
kick me out of my word with you dude
yeah so yeah so he gets the toy wagon
and he you know takes her body out and
takes it back yourself yeah okay so once
he gets the body back to the house
obviously she's not not great a shape
yeah so what you guys is he puts the
bones back together with like coat
hangers and like twisted wires and
they're like that like reconstruct those
she was falling for well yeah and I said
it had been they'll get here enough
she's like the mother walking
that one yes it was Bobby um yeah man
who's nut I know and like I said it just
being weird that that he had never done
anything like this before or that they
know of maybe he did and they just never
brought him but you know it was right
separated from his wife yeah maybe she
liked me maybe maybe she found his stash
of like necro horn did I wonder zoom
necrophiliac horn in 1930 I'm sure they
know you don't think they have to
contacted a they asked them for Canada
they did please how can people pretend
like you're dead yeah well that's a
fetish - that's like it that's like kind
of a separate fetishy people that like
to pretend they're dead I guess it's
very rare for people to actually be in
it but there are some there are some so
yeah so you know he puts the skeleton
back together with wire he puts glass
eyes in there because that's not creepy
at all because I guess she didn't have
any eyeballs laughs yeah I would think
and you know obviously the more rotten
she got she would um her Carl rather
would put like would kind of patch her
up with a with silk like he had like
this silk cloth and he would soak it in
wax and plaster yeah and then so he was
basically making a paper mache over yeah
or rotted flesh now here's one of the
weirdest things to me right like for the
hair because obviously her hair falling
out and started falling out
so he made a wig now he made a wig out
of her actual hair because her family
had given him her hair like after she
died like given him some of her hair
because I guess he asked and they were
like okay Wow to me that seems like a
very strange yeah I mean like if I don't
know in a way that almost kind of
suggests that maybe she did kind of love
him back because I don't know if you
every system Brando or just your doctor
I didn't like that and after she died
and then like this guy comes up he's
like hey would you mind terribly if I
took some of your dead daughter's hair
I think that and they're all like yeah I
know prom I think the parents
just desperate for medical treatment for
the daughter they're going to put up
with anything to get some free medical
treatment you know try and attempt to
saber this maybe it's just I don't know
that seems really weird to me because
I'm sitting there going and it's funny
because most of the stories about you
know most of the things that are written
about this they don't even really
comment on that oh oh he made a wig out
of hair that the family had given us
like what yeah let's unpack that
consider him a friend of the family I
guess but still I would think even look
even if I had a friend of the family and
somebody died that and they asked for
the hair I'd be like bro no all right
that's [__] creepy stop it but yeah
so so yeah he's he's kind of paper mache
in his dream girl back together you know
filling her up with the rags and stuff
like that and now he um kept her in his
bed yeah okay
and he kept spraying perfume on it and
new deodorants and like they didn't have
for breeze back then but you know that
type of thing
nasty odor and that doesn't work all
dead people smell is like the worst
thing ever it's like can you imagine
what his [__] house probably fell yeah
yeah oh my god but um so now some
reports say that he put a paper tube
yeah up her bed yeah for the nefarious
purpose yeah um and it has everything I
think it had lips on it and everything
like that so you could have sex with it
oh my god now see it would surprise me
very much if he wasn't having sex with
it I don't know if the paper tube was
really there or if that would just kind
of came about later but um yeah I mean
the fact that he that he was in love
with her and that he's keeping it in the
bed and stuff like haha are you gonna
need a shower
yes is it a stuff is the powerful but
yeah so apparently he got away with this
for quite a while she was in his house
until 1940 so how long we talk and that
was like when I was like seven years
right yeah because I think he didn't
take her
body out of the grave until 1933 how did
he get discovered well evidently there
were rumors going around I heard that a
little boy in the neighborhood had
walked by Tambor's house and had seen
him dancing with what looked like a doll
like a girl like he was dancing around
his living room with it in his arms and
also the family were suspicious when he
stopped visiting the doll in - I mean he
had stopped visiting that well before
but but then I think this her sister
florinda like kind of put two and two
together and was like I don't think she
thought that he had stolen the body
necessarily but um she maybe wondered
you know what the [__] does he have like
a life-sized doll of my sister that's
super weird and she's so Florinda I mean
for her you know in her defense I mean
she went right to the house of like a
[__] bro yeah yeah you know I mean
what's going on so yeah she went over to
the house the sister heard rumors that
he was sleeping with a disinterred body
the sisters yeah yeah so it whatever was
going around that's what I mean like I
said I heard that a little boy had seen
like he's like why he danced with his
big doll in there so I think people kind
of started putting to the rock genre and
they knew I mean it's kind of a smaller
community so maybe it was kind of
getting around that he was everybody yes
he went for whoever he was and maybe the
smell may be it may be really bad I mean
you know how that sounds around her so
um yeah so the sister was like you know
arrest this freak and they did and they
did find the body in there now Carlton's
lured they actually did give him a
psychiatric evaluation obviously as you
would but they thought that he was
competent to stand trial so you know he
had a hearing it's you know for just
removing a body that officer
authorization destroying a grave yatta
yatta now he ended up getting released
because one the statute of limitations
had expired on the crime because it's
not I mean you can look like I said on
Wikipedia
robbery itself yeah now it's a felony in
some states but in others just a
misdemeanor okay it's usually was not
like a super big deal I mean as long as
you got didn't kill the person or
anything like that yes nasty but you
know you're not hurting the person so
and the odd thing too is that in the
community there was actually kind of a
lot of sympathy for him yeah because it
was kind of like oh it's a great love
story it was kind of wet romantic morbid
I think they were reading into was
romantic right yes but at any rate you
know he got he actually got off now oh
he got off I'm sure yes in more ways
than one I know I watch out of that
denied that was give them you pick right
up on that now here's the thing okay
Carl Tam blur right a creepy dude right
but I have to say that the surrounding
community of Key West maybe not much
better because after her body had been
taken out of his house they put the
[__] body on display in the Ripley's
Believe It or Not museum yeah or not you
know or they put it in it in a museum
yeah for people to come by and look at
it
Dean Lopez funeral home rather Ripley's
Believe It or Not museum in Key West
actually has a fake set up of it because
it's kind of a famous thing that
happened in Key West
I'm done ready to walk off you think out
of this show I'm just doesn't at all I
could take this [__] man it is like
skiing down it's nasty and yeah and you
know make my skin crawl and I'm have to
take a shower after this no just this is
like a businessman [__] you go up with
yeah you are this is how I did that hey
this was your idea yeah what you no idea
did we're all fans what wasn't your
relative needs details it's like
something out of a horror novel I know I
love it yeah no one writes stuff like
this yeah and her horn I love this [__]
I don't understand I can't I can't this
is why I can never get him to watch like
true crime [__] with me as been always
like it see I love that [__] but he's
not wanted
but um yeah so like I said community not
so much better they put the body like
the paper mache like your body they put
it on display this [__] funeral home
and almost
7,000 people I came through to see and
I'm sure they probably [__] charges
it his reason she did and it pimp her
out when she did that that's I mean it's
like not much better you guys know
better okay
and so like yeah there was like a big
sensation in the media it was like crazy
and like all these people just thought
it was super romantic and all this other
stuff and yeah like I said he didn't he
didn't get a prison or anything like
that but you know it here's the thing so
he got off and you know I guess he you
know he just went on and had the rest of
his life he actually wrote an off you
wrote an autobiography which I don't you
know I actually loved to read that it
was in the magazine fantastic adventures
which like a cult publication now he his
ex-wife here's another thing that's
weird his ex-wife Doris I guess I don't
know if they were still married but they
were separated because he had left her
in Zephyrhills years before but she
supported them like so the rest of his
life so uh what I don't know whatever
and he actually he had a death mask of
Maria Elena and he made it like a
life-size doll okay that he kept until
he died so yeah he had a life-size FG of
it so he had basically a sexologist
didn't have a rotting corpse it in
anymore
which I guess is marginally I could have
gone that way the first time exactly why
didn't you just do die on the start then
that would have been weird but not bad
this is Matt I'm sorry I'm so sorry
good mash the show why are you getting
mad Malthus if so you getting mad yeah I
told you this is your idea is good then
yeah oh this is your idea I was wrong
and what I'm just trying to get through
another show just trying to come up with
another show and I just came to top my
head I said maybe the audience will like
this one now you're picking through it
it's very good and this is why like he
specifically told me because sometimes
here's how we do show it's like
sometimes we'll come up with you know
we'll come up with a topic usually at
the last like a minute and then I
usually do all the research for it now
sometimes depending what the topic is
sometimes all kind of read him some of
the Reese
yes like that no I already know or if it
doesn't he already knows I really better
sometimes better not for me not to know
that way I can react to it kind of like
the way the audience would react to it
yeah
which was the case in this yeah show
because I've been you know that's how I
spent most of my weekend researching
necrophilia so I'm just sharing some of
the fun with you these daddy I know but
see I like I said I've been reading this
[__] for two days you've been sitting
here for one hour and he specifically
told me not to tell him yet because I
started telling him about the animal
necrophilia thing because I thought that
was the assassin I know about that I
thought that was super fascinating that
like birds Alexis or something this
person is my car I like that just
[__] crack - I thought this was
wrongness in nature that is just like
yet to exist is to be wrong that's how
bad yeah so like I'm saying so
necrophilia in humans now it's like yeah
it's still creepy and weird
but now it's like oh now then it's not
as weird anymore because I guess [__]
animals do so so it's not really that's
profit in it but you know some longer
than that those animals don't know any
better that's a little see something
that is their own species may jump on it
and they go it's not fight it's not what
you know awesome well I'm just gonna
have you bon hunger tricky Pocky I don't
think everybody realizes oh man maybe
they do maybe they're into you know
pretty free that doesn't mean I think
it's I think it's more opportunism yet
but anyway the case of Carl Kanzler
actually kind of struck a chord in
popular culture
[__] there [__] loads of life songs
about him and stuff like that I think
get it and you will know it by the trail
is dead they didn't talk about him yeah
and you know they did like [__]
there's a band called The Black Dahlia
Murder
and they did a song about him and you
know there's lots of other one I'm like
I said the Ripley's Believe It or Not
museum in Key West which I don't know if
it's still there now like oh because we
look pretty far from Key West we
literally know what you know they used
to have you know a thing of Carl tanner
and Maria Elena like him preparing her
her corpse or whatever so I guess they
had like a little
fake thing of that I don't know if still
there or not but um yeah so
necrophilia you guys it's here's the
interesting thing like I said and since
I had to read about necrophilia all
weekend night are you here about thought
about this again yes
well yeah because we we still have a
couple minutes in show but um out of all
the people that have the necrophiliac
fetish that they've studied they broke
it down into like percentages of their
motives right the overwhelming majority
of them 68 percent as a matter of fact
their whole motivation was for an
unresisting partner yeah yeah so that's
got that is the by and large the
greatest motivation and then down from
that 21 percent of Nazi that got a
living person was resistance yeah that's
what definitely happened it will see
that was another thing that I kind of
found fascinating about these two guys
is they weren't like repulsive or
anything like that like they weren't
repulsive looking they weren't like you
know they just look like normal dudes
we're they just you know their brains
were just broken but you know the next
went down 21% it's because you know
their spouse diet or whatever and they
don't want to maintain connection which
I guess is the most understandable only
15 percent genuinely attracted to dead
people
Oh only 15 percent so if that makes you
feel any better that's not that many
people and you know and then is a
smaller percentage that that you know
they have low self-esteem which I guess
probably all of them do but they have
low self-esteem and they want to express
power over a dead person which seems
dumb to make is I'm like the dead person
doesn't know that you're expressing
power over them yeah one thing that
matters is then yeah they can't express
how are we living people say yeah yeah
so um hopefully you guys enjoyed the
show much more than tanden guy like this
hahaha but as again and i'm going to
repeat that this is his idea okay yeah
this is true hi Jacob ah yeah I came I
came up with the Anatoly angle because I
discovered him while I was researching
Carl Sandburg I could kind of handle
that
you know I mean because just if I wasn't
really having sex with them you know
yeah he makin dolls out of but you know
it would always dude yeah a Napoleon
almost seemed like it I won't talk about
it like he was like a father say we're
walking out of shut no you can't no you
can't it's not a writ I'm not walking
out walk it out this is the first time
this has happened on the history of
circuses let's not talk about it anymore
well I'll have to do the end part now
okay I'm not talking by the airport I'm
not talking about anymore okay I promise
I'm not talking about a little work I
promise I'm not talking about it anymore
this is hilarious oh man now that I know
that this is how you're going to react
now but a purpose or the condition
bothers me but not now this is what the
more I see more of the more you keep
talking about more I think about the
worse it is
yeah I get I have like I have like a
really dark sense of you know actually
this is enough like it it's not exactly
funny to me I mean I guess it kind of is
but I don't know it wrap it up rather
the bottom and I'll just be quiet wrap
it up trying keep trying hung it back
you keep trying to bring it back okay
I'm getting a conversation well why
don't you do the end part see get your
mind up it no yeah she doesn't even
remember one possession though I'm
disoriented okay good man I did not have
that yesterday I thought Mike Edwards
well anyway like I said hopefully
enjoyed this [__] one day and if you
like the show please head on over to the
patreon of the what mal your method Mia
the project Entertainment Network
patreon that's what I meant to say go to
their patreon page which is patreon.com
slash project internet and give them a
buck or two that's who hosts our audio
version and if you like our youtube
channel you know you can go over there
and follow us over there follow us on
Twitter Zora 10 o'clock podcast we have
a Facebook page 13 o'clock podcast also
we still have t-shirts I still just have
to 5 but we're going to do other ones
maybe I'll do one for this show haha and
Tom will not want one but
so you know I'll bring it up okay well
no I have to bring it up one more time
because I have to say for a musical
interlude at the end this is the first
song I thought of when I thought about
this topic we got to do Type O Negative
okay so we're going to put some sec when
I get a violin so uh anyway well we will
see you guys next Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]